the founder of project Veritas a
conservative non-profit known for its
hidden camera stings is under
investigation by a Suburban New York
prosecutor's office in the latest
Fallout after his ouster from the group
over allegations that he mistreated
workers they're not going to say exactly
what it's all about
or what he's being investigated for and
maybe this goes nowhere
but I'm not going to ignore this because
we don't want to be frogs in a pot
boiling James O'Keefe had a number of
Investigations that aided Donald Trump
there were videos of there was one video
we had where our woman was filling out
ballots for another one remember that
one there was one where a guy was in his
car saying look at all these bouts that
I've collected I get paid for these
now this is not exactly what I meant my
what I thought was likely to happen
first and they haven't charged James
O'Keefe or anything like that
my prediction is not necessarily Tucker
but somebody who was in communication
with the Trump legal team who was then
going on TV and going on the internet
and advocating for Trump's election
claims and assisting and rallying people
or some of these people who were
saying things like encouraging people to
go out to go out January 6 and literally
be violent those are the people I think
they go after first
but this is still in the periphery of
what I thought might happen James
O'Keefe project Veritas
you know look
this is interesting
Fox shutters
Tucker Carlson they shut him down so he
goes and does his own thing they're
Furious about it they try to to sideline
James O'Keefe he resists he then
launches his own organization they
cannot stop him
the only thing they can do is make some
fake bogus some bogus charges against
them and stop him through legal Force I
mean the reality is they're so desperate
they're losing that's why they're trying
these tactics but I'm telling you I see
them going after James O'Keefe because
of this I'm going to introduce just a
slight note of skepticism on this which
is it is possible that James O'Keefe
violated you know New York State labor
laws right
um well sure a lot of things are
possible but I really don't believe that
sure sure okay but but my point is that
precisely because
they've become so politicized
um these kinds of Investigations that no
one can you know like even if he did it
you're like oh it must be because of his
speech and that's the problem because I
care about I care about Labor rights and
I want labor laws upheld but in a case
like this and given the backdrop of how
the how the sort of official left has
behaved you can't help but think this is
a kind of political persecution even if
it may be a legitimate case and I know
you're saying it probably isn't but I'm
just saying it could be anybody you if
you offered someone the opportunity to
place a bet is this a political
prosecution or legitimate anybody
willing to take the legitimate bet
they're welcome to play my poker games I
I mean but I I think that you're on
something with your broader point and
I've I've mentioned this before the fact
that
there's so many people now that don't
trust the government and and look I was
I've been a like a Libertarian kind of
dude for these like almost 15 years or
so and so I'm real quick to be like you
know government knowing I want to cut
the government blah blah blah but when
it comes to the average you know what
you'd call Normie I really think covid
in the vaccine has really really opened
up a massive massive new uh group of
people that just don't trust the
government they just don't believe what
their talent you know what the
government says and stuff and I you know
I'm not sure what that means for for the
country like
low trust societies are violent
societies low-trust Societies or
societies that have weaker economies
there's there's more uh just more
friction you need more lawyers in low
trust societies you need more uh more
more courts more everything is harder in
a low trust society and the more that we
do things
that separate people from each other and
and make people look at class
differences and race differences and and
stop focusing on the fact that you know
we have liberal principles that unify us
as a country we don't need to worry
about your skin color we don't need to
worry about your religion all you have
to do is understand liberal principles
and and accept the fact that people
should be allowed to to decide how their
own lives should be structured and and
it's easy for us to get along but if we
can't
if we can't allow people to live their
lives the way that they see fit I I
don't know how you you fix the problem
if you of a low trust Society well and
but so here's here I mean to talk about
a little bit about the book
um
precisely there are possibilities for
private coercion in the marketplace
right yeah
um there is a kind of free market theory
that imagines that we're still in the
late 18th century and you just have you
know independent farmers and mechanics
and Artisans who can trade at arm's
length that is not what the American
kind of economy looks like most
Industries are super concentrated
there's two or three predominant Sellers
and everyone else especially if you're a
worker you're at the mercy of it's like
the wage is no longer uh the perfect
crystallization of supply and demand
it's it's an index of relative
bargaining power and so those are issues
that government can help with
um and I I believe should so for example
the fact that in this country half of
fast food workers have to rely on public
welfare to make ends meet that is not
good we had so we have what's called a a
low-wage high Welfare Society why is
that bad it by the way it's not when we
call it high welfare it's not like the
welfare benefits are actually especially
generous in some ways they're quite
miserly but it just means that as a
share of income for kind of the lower
third of the country the share of the
income they need to make ends meet
welfare makes up a big part of that and
wages are not sufficient so what we're
doing is as taxpayers we're subsidizing
you know low wages communism and and at
the same time you know workers in that
position are not only subject to the
whims of the boss but they're also
subject to the whims of the welfare
administrator who gets more and more
powerful because he controls the fate of
more and more people so those are
problems where we need to work together
democratically to try to solve
and if people are constantly thinking
that Government is out to get them to
try to like impose irrational mask
mandates and so forth it becomes harder
and so this is uh I'm really just kind
of dittoing your point
because there are problems that need
kind of collective action yeah and if
you don't believe in the government if
you have a society that just generally
doesn't believe that other the other
people that they're trying to work with
are actually you know looking to
actually solve problems as opposed to
just a choir or a mass power for
themselves or their constituents I mean
you know people complain about where the
where the country's heading and stuff
well the best way to make sure that the
country is heading in a good direction
is to be able to trust that you can
enter into contract and you can you know
your your economy is going to work well
and you can trust it your neighbors
aren't going to steal your stuff you
know and the government's not going to
take your property and where we're going
with these prosecutions yeah it it hits
the nail on the head of the hammer
Helena with hammer exactly what the
founding fathers talked about when they
talked about
being innocent until proven guilty
if a society tells you that no matter
how good of a person you are they will
lock you up and punish you then there is
no incentive to be good so what we see
with things like this is lawlessness and
Arco tyranny people are looting these
stores Mass raids and they get away with
it you defend yourself you go to prison
that guy in New York who was being
attacked and then stabbed the guy and
went to Rikers and it was only because
of public outcry that he got out how
many people do you think right now in
this country in these cities have
suffered a similar fight and we just
don't know about it it's an inversion
and the reason is it's really simple it
is easier for the police to arrest James
O'Keefe than it is for them to arrest
one random guy looting a Nike store why
the guy living in the Nike store could
have a knife a gun and he'll fight James
O'Keefe will open the door turn around
put his hands behind his back and let
you arrest him so what what are they
going to keep doing law enforcement will
go after low-hanging fruit to a hammer
everything looks like a nail and if
there if there is some politicized
charge against any of these uh
Republicans or media personalities
people like James O'Keefe then they'll
do it and the cops are going to be like
well you know this one's easy
that's it
then what happens
when I when I so Tucker he's putting up
his video with Trump so when he asks
Trump if if he thinks right towards the
Civil War I'm really interested to see
what Trump says I imagine Trump's going
to say no I'm not sure I mean maybe he
says yes considering what's going on
but you got to understand
that if
this anarcho tyranny persists eventually
the view is
doj is illegitimate yeah and and and why
would anyone think otherwise even right
now certainly Democrats would agree with
it but that's not what what matters what
matters is do we as a nation agree that
our department of justice is a
legitimate Force for justice or do we
believe it is simply a gang run by
partisans to torture and oppress their
political enemies I'm pretty sure every
Trump supporter believes the latter and
if that's the case there comes a time
when you're say a fat 70 year old dude
in Provo Utah and they show up at just
the battering ram and then they kill you
yeah I mean there was just the uh just
like with yesterday or day before was
the anniversary of Ruby Ridge oh yeah
that's right yeah I think yesterday but
Ruby were just a little bit different it
is you know yeah they Shot Firearms
charge and then they tried using a
justification for a raid you look at
that and you look at um Waco and that
was they found a bunch of guns or
whatever and then there's controversy
over those may have been something
there's more of those stories we don't
know about right it's not it's so simple
today we're dealing with something overt
and desperate the Democrats have lost
everything
they're losing music they're losing
movies they're losing culture in general
and in their panic and Desperation
they're going for Brute Force and that
will just shatter what is left of
confidence in their legitimacy
then what happens I honestly don't know
you know uh what happens when we get to
the point where they kill that guy in
Provo Utah
there's that woman that school teacher
in Chicago she was threatening Trump and
Baron and they show up and just arrest
her peacefully
to be fair you know some frail little
woman who's not known to be armed is a
big difference is very different from a
guy posting photos of himself with
rifles at least the guy that couldn't
walk has guns we don't know that she had
it you know so but what happens when
that Provo Utah thing kind of expands
what happens when you get seven guys who
don't plot anything ridiculous aren't
talking about going to the governor's
match or anything like that but they
just say
we none of us believe that the doj is
legitimate what happens then when the
FBI shows up and they they've got a car
blocking the highway and they say you
turn right around you don't you've got
nothing to say here we got nothing to
say to you turn around what happens when
people stop respecting the badges of
these law enforcement because they're
doing things like going after Trump and
Trump's lawyers well to be fair I mean
you you see the increase in crime in in
cities and that's because the people
that are living in the cities don't
respect the police you know exactly
that's my point yeah so I mean you'll
you'll see more of this you'll see more
unrest and then you know will people
will citizens take in take it into their
own hands because you're seeing more and
more where people are sick and tired of
it I don't know that they're gonna you
know there's that you just we just saw
the dude I think in uh Atlanta where the
D.A is not going to charge him for
smoking the guy that was uh robbing
someone oh the gas station yeah the guy
that just no no that was Michigan it was
Michigan the gas station with the six
pack and he shoots
he doesn't put the beer down he just
pops the dude yep and see here's the
issue we went too far in One Direction
maybe I I do think that in many ways we
are winning and I think we're on track
to win I don't know if that's a
guarantee I don't know what's going on
but when you see there's a store out of
Michigan where a guy with a box card a
threat he's threatening the store the
clerk some dude who's got a concealed
carry just shoots him and they said
we're not going to prosecute him he's
allowed to do it also the good guy right
he was a security he had previously
works as a security guard and uh wow one
hand holding a six-pack and he and he
stopped this this evil Criminal
that's that's the good news is if we as
a society say we will not prosecute you
for defending other people maybe it's
not that these individuals Don't Fear
the police anymore so they fear everyone
else absolutely it is 100 a deterrent if
people are armed
in if you live in a place where people
are armed and you might get shot that is
a deter that deters people from trying
to commit crimes but we live in a super
armed Society
why why is it also a high crime because
it's it's extremely hard to carry guns
in some places most places probably I
mean it's it's in West Virginia they
have concealed carry uh I'm sorry
constitutional care yeah so uh so long
as you have an ID for the state you can
walk into a gun store you buy a gun you
got to fill out the federal background
check form wait for that to clear
usually it takes like 10 15 minutes uh
it could take days
then once you take the gun you can put
it in your your holster and your
waistband or under your coat or whatever
you got and you can walk out but a lot
of states don't have that and even
states that are actually kind of okay
like Texas I think Texas recently passed
constitutional carry but for a while you
did take a test you had to do a course
on a handgun training course Maryland's
the same way
for a lot of people it's not so easy to
do and so the areas where you'd think
you would need the weapon high crime
urban areas are the hardest place to get
hardest places to get weapons and not
only that in places like Chicago where
after it was uh what was the what was
the ruling in 2008 I keep forgetting the
name yeah not Bruin um Heller
after that all of a sudden it's like
okay Chicago can't stop you from having
a handgun but no building will let you
in if you do yeah but the more more
importantly why is it that these
criminals don't fear anybody might be
armed because if you defend yourself you
go to jail if you try to defend others
you go to jail look at uh uh what was
the guy's name penny in New York
there's a guy in a train threatening to
kill everyone on the train so him and
two other guys subdue him they charged
him
with with uh manslaughter I was second
degree manslaughter then you got the guy
in Austin
who is driving Uber and a far left
extremist walks up with a rifle at low
ready and aims it he shoots going to
jail he got sentenced that was uh was
that that was Perry I think yeah and a
lot of Harry and pennies yeah a lot of
anarchists have a problem with it
because the uh the dude with the AK was
an anarchist but like they both had guns
so he just lost a gunfight dude you
can't be part of a mob yeah you can't
and walk up to a guy in his vehicle yeah
with a with a weapon at low ready with
you holding it up
um you just can't do that man if you're
if your hands off the weapon thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time